hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
i'm gonna give you
three jump scares right now and that way
you won't have to worry about them later
this way
you'll see them coming you won't be
afraid of them you can start to get used
to the fear and it can make you enjoy
the video more now the first one's
coming up in about five
seconds and then the other two will come
at any moment after the first one okay
cool
any minute now
it's right around the corner
don't worry
it's coming
lexie and you gonna
i thought you were in charge of that i
thought you pushed the button in like it
did it jumps
that's not you then who does the jump
scares
hi
this game uses sound based mechanics so
it is important that you will be able to
hear them clearly before you continue
make sure you turn the volume up enough
that you hear the heart beating the game
is also best played with headphones yeah
this seems like a trap
but i can hear the heartbeat
welcome to omniphobia
the demo all right start new
profile name merkle
oh go go who left these stains on the
ground
also where am i
oh it's a trail i'm supposed to follow
it probably
at least it's different from the typical
wake up in a bed kind of start to a game
i can't exactly fault those because some
of the scarier ones have been starting
in a bed
waking up in the middle of now hey
well you're fun oh
hey how you doing hey good oh
hello is that a pillow oh no it's a
letter susan
you should be looking out for something
like what the big weird trees
were checkerboard dildos what's a what's
the deal
follow me well i kind of have been you
know
keep going oh you tricky
come on now don't get distracted like
you usually do hey
i have adhd man you can't say that kind
of stuff to me
i'm ugly hey you and me both why does
everyone hate me i never hurt them in
any way
the only friend i have is you well i
don't even know who you are
but okay i'll be your friend you do like
me right do you i don't know
well fine shush now it's time to sleep
boy you are bossy i'm asleep
what 8 p.m battery 100 oh
god what am i doing what what
what what is happening oh what
where where what what is happening
up down where is anything make me go
this is weird this is weird
what the hell is this i have a feeling
there's something behind you flick the
mouse at the bottom of the screen
[Laughter]
well i don't like that i can tell you
that much i do not like
oh my god i didn't know this was gonna
be a five nights at freddy's type thing
holy crap oh
oh i hate it i love the art style but i
hate it
ooh hey bud well you look fun
oh yeah this is uh this is uncomfortable
this is
uncomfortable all right so no one's in
the turrets
oh god okay so there's some kind of a
some kind of a something there i got
nothing there we go
okay what are you what are you
woody what are you you're fine it's fine
probably fine
bruh this is creepy oh god
okay so the navigation is a little odd
still don't know what that's about
but it seems fine i guess all right i
don't
what what do you mean oh it's gone
oh whoa whoa easy tiger its battery goes
down really fast
you don't want it to run out goodness
this would turn into a nightmare
okay i love the little door
i love the cardboard everything i mean i
hate it it's awful
but you know oh god oh no
oh we got movement oh hey you're in the
turret
oh you're not in the turret where is you
in
where where are you being oh god
oh hey oh lordy lou
what do i do okay then b uh is that like
one of the
uh uh this way is it the vent i don't
know
is that the vent oh now you better check
the monitor you'd be able to see all of
susan's thoughts and memories
i thought i was i can't get out of this
well that was quite a kaboom
all right game okay all right okay all
right
okay all right i don't know if i'm gonna
start okay good i'm here
well i guess good i don't know if it's
good how was i supposed to avoid that it
kind of just happened
because it says something about event
and i'm assuming
i'm assuming that it those two things
are vents and i just don't open one of
those
that one's on the right and the other
one's on the left and i'm assuming
that's just the way it is
you suck you know at least initially we
seem to be okay
and then i i don't know do i need to
check back here or something how long
does the night last it starts at ten
i'm guessing it goes to six probably
that's too many hours
[Laughter]
what am i looking at okay so that's
apparently on the move
dude am i supposed to like keep an eye
on them
i see you so i'm supposed to whoa who
just
hey you watch yourself
uh so they're trying to mosey you're
trying to
mosey ah you are trying to mosey
okay interesting oh how did you mosey
how the hell did you mosey but i
oh my god
oh my god look at that bod
oh my god i'm so focused on you i don't
know if i'm missing out on anyone else
it doesn't look like it but you're
standing up now so that's probably not
good
oh don't do that to me
what's up yeah i see oh
i i saw that i god damn it i saw that
okay so clearly not
good whatever's happening and i'm
clearly running out of battery which is
also
not good okay
you're still there which is bizarre
oh oh oh god
okay we're fine we're not fine but we're
fine
this is uh concerning
very concerning oh you're in the
bathroom
oh god you're in the bathroom uh i'm
assuming oh you're not in the bathroom
oh god where are you vent vent okay it's
fine
hey what the hell i was looking and it
didn't look
ugh i don't know where you are i don't
want to know where you are but i
also do want to know where you are oh
god
what do you do what is happening there
something's going on there
oh my god what is that oh
god what is that oh no hey wait a minute
wait a minute wait hold
flip oh
don't do it note get back i hate
you
you'll never get me you'll never get me
did i do it did i defend myself
did i defend my honor i think i did
okay i think it what was that something
other than no no no
oh i hate it hate this hit all of this
oh get out i don't want you
screw off screw oh
oh okay you're
you're over there now okay that's good
i'm guessing so far so okay
oh you're trying again huh well i'm not
even gonna change the vent
door where's that oh what do i do
about that okay
i'm gonna switch the vents go oh my god
switch them
[Music]
oh what do i do about that that might
just open i'm screwed
oh my god
okay all right well that's bad um oh but
you're still there but you're still
there is the thing
oh oh
i'm alive okay uh great uh wow
that was terrifying that was terror i
hated that
i hated that i hated that a lot
oh my god is there more go frick
susan you should be looking out for
something what
what follow me i am
you're ugly so are you no one likes you
you must have hurt them in some way
the only friend you have is me oh find
the golden ball
all right oh no
the golden ball shift to run i don't
even know
where i am how can i find a golden ball
oh
well invisible wall i guess helps guide
me
oh okay oh golden
[Applause]
ball
well this seems like a trap kind of like
an angler fish situation but i'm going
for it
full sprint baby i found it
i i'm standing on it hello
i found it what do i do about the golden
ball
i've done it oh another one perfect
excellent thank you golden ball
which one which one have i not been to
this one golden ball
golden ball oh interesting oh
something weird about this one
[Music]
hmm
well this doesn't seem good i'm not a
hard presenter oh hey
hey there i enjoy cooking especially
baking
that's great oh hey there i enjoy eating
cupcakes and having tea parties you
should join us oh
okay all right
sure hey there i love seeing my family
and spending time with them do you have
a family
oh you know i don't know
hey there out of my favorite things to
do is read what's your favorite book
one of my favorite things
hey there i'm happy and full of joy do
you want to play
yeah only oh
oh god oh god no not like this
[Laughter]
this needs to sound familiar let's go
and find this music box yeah
yeah okay yeah all right
you cheap you cheap you
cheat
oh no not this again i mean this must be
turning into a new norm for us right
yeah uh-huh yeah uh-huh yeah
uh-huh yeah uh-huh okay so
i don't know what the deal is with this
place is i don't know if i just turn
around and kind of like
check whenever i hear noise because i
could probably get a lot
done if i only have to do that but it
doesn't seem like an
efficient way to play what are you doing
there you weirdo
hmm i think we've got some more bad
memories tonight keep a lookout bad
memories you say oh they're already
on the move oh you are where are you
okay
little rude there don't you think i'll
just keep an eye on the cameras
memory four memory three there's
something about that memory four
memory three watching you i'm watching
you oh
is there supposed to be something i
can do to prevent let me see
what if i yeah yeah yeah take that
take that nerd and then they start over
at the back okay
i think it's only when they're like all
the way over on the left
or you know the farthest side okay now
they must have tried
no my theory was wrong i was wrong
ah there there you oh boy
ah well damn it um well shoot uh huh
wait what the hell is that oh what the
hell is that
oh what the hell is that oh no you don't
oh hey buddy hey
[Applause]
you look why
oh hey uh if you feel like one of them
is about to get you watch them on the
monitor that will make them stop moving
for a bit uh
okay well you know uh oh
not that that's not what i meant oh okay
stop moving stop moving stop stop moving
stop moving stop moving
stop oh you moved
stay there
oh two doors damn it
okay good we're on the right one no none
of that
none of that what the hell what the hell
oh god oh
god no oh god no
oh well i'm screwed aren't i i'm dead
i'm
so dead a million ways from sunday i'm
dead
oh i'm a dead man who walks around
oh i'm dead i'm so dead
oh my god i'm dead
what what is that
you gonna honk a horn at me is that what
you're gonna do
why'd you honk a horn at me you
horn honker who does that
oh oh oh
oh dude oh
oh
well this is probably good you know this
is probably good
probably a good thing i've seen some
good things in my life and this is
definitely one of them
oh is them's eyeballs is that what we're
dealing with
oh no it's a truck the horn honking
don't run me over i'm begging you
don't run me over please
okay
i woke up at 6 00 am you'll be well good
right
isn't that the idea i hooked him with
6am
what the hell the hell man
that was cool i really like that like
it's been a while since i played
a five nights at freddy's fan game by
the way and i don't even know if you
could
qualify this as that other than just
like it had camera mechanics because it
doesn't seem to be like thematically
inspired by five nights at freddy's at
all it's just mechanically inspired
which
can mean it's its own thing like that's
really cool i think
this is dope i love the styling reminds
me of like flumpties and stuff like that
but
creepier like the art is so childish but
terrifying you know what i mean i love
bridging that gap perfectly and i think
this game does it
really well very good i like it a lot
very very good okay cool
moving on
[Music]
this is the light keeper have you seen
the movie the lighthouse
this is not based on that but they both
have lighthouses in them
so let's do this i needed to get out of
town
the town for a while so i decided to
take up a job offer as a light keeper
which i didn't even know that was a job
anymore i was hoping that i could be
alone but apparently it's mandatory that
i had a partner i guess they can't leave
a newcomer to the field all alone in the
middle of the ocean
it's going to be a long month i just
hope all goes well
something tells me not all is going to
go well
damn it's got a whopping three pixels to
this game
is that my cell phone or is that a
foghorn
still not sure
yeah this isn't ominous at all something
definitely isn't gonna come charging
down the road at me
directly in a few moments any minute now
[Music]
oh god it's a lighthouse coming straight
at me
or a penis i should go turn off that
foghorn why
isn't that what's necessary
let me get a good listen to this
oh that's the good okay thank you
oh to go inside yeah i couldn't jump in
the barrel
[Music]
i'm holding space
oh i did it
i'm the greatest thank you
and uh you're welcome everybody else for
saving your eardrums
sorry to all the it was there a light
over there there two lighthouses better
not be
mine's better one's bigger way bigger
hello i love that there's a painting of
a lighthouse inside the lighthouse
and i bet inside that lighthouse is
another painting oh boy skewey
it is about the lighthouse
[Music]
that your partner will not be showing up
uh due to the weather
so you you'll be on there uh until
further notice
[Music]
okay thanks uh cassette player radio
definitely a two-way communication
device definitely something that's real
uh yeah if you haven't seen lighthouse
the movie it's very good i would
recommend watching it but it's pretty
much about beans lighthouses and a lot
of masturbation
that's pretty much the top three
ingredients in that one
who the hell turned that on okay
my partner must be here oh boy my
partner
can't wait to frolic into their arms
we're gonna have a lovely time
it's locked
hello uh well that's interesting
i think somebody is here with me do you
behind door number one partner
[Applause]
radio into check
[Music]
yeah that's how stereos work
partner hey
[Music]
should i escape or investigate is this
really a choice
is oh oh oh
someone bled on my paintings someone
bled all over my paintings
i'm gonna investigate i'm a brave man
i'm big and brave who's down here
someone gonna come charging out of the
darkness oh god oh please no please
anything but that i hate that it's the
worst ah
a skeleton a big
handprint blooded
more blood and what's that another
skeleton
you're never alone on this rock okay
thank you
oh i'm dead now i'm dead i'm i'm
dead i am dead i'm dead i am dead
i spilled my beans
why did i have to spill my beans i think
the moral of the story is
when you are in a horror situation and
you have the option to escape
you should take that so i'm gonna do
exactly that
okay i think someone's in here with me
somebody's downstairs
uh i'm gonna escape goodbye later nerd
idiot i'm getting back to my boat you'll
never stop me
i'm making a run for it there's no one
behind me definitely
oh i am oh i'm running
i'm running baby oh serpentine
we oh is there someone behind me oh
there's someone behind me
not today not today not today boat boat
idiot yeah
stupid you thought you could give me
your full four
was that a wave oh
why
yeah okay all right
man that stereo really has a lot of
interesting properties
two-way radio and floats and works in
the water and the rain
that's a good one it's a good stereo
high quality
[Music]
all right well moral of the story is
never run away from your problems
always face them head on
i think we all learned that valuable
lesson okay i think that
there might be like some secret but you
can try to find it for yourself if you
want to but that was pretty good
it didn't really carry a sense of dread
that i was hoping it had some spooky
moments
obviously it's not like drawing from the
movie lighthouse other than you know
you're at a lighthouse and it's supposed
to be two dudes and there's that
painting there but
it is interesting i do like it you can
check it out for yourself not bad
all right
this one is undiscovered house
so i will discover it
turns out i'm discovering it
25 miles to go
almost home yeah
hope i don't discover any houses on the
way
whoa okay
all right
okay all right little weird
oh
oh my head
what happened here god damn
or were you traveling with fireworks see
a path maybe it leads to a house
maybe at least to undiscovered
home i mean you never know about these
things it could be anything oh there
i found the path and i will walk it
awfully dark tonight
weird blood red sky which is probably
normal
does this house not like have a driveway
or anything like that
oh there she is okay wow i've discovered
it
that's always a good sign there's
something in the window there
i saw that i saw that you
you think you can just be in your own
home
i'm gonna go into your house and i'm
gonna royally screw up your day
try me try me hello is anyone home
anybody what he said what i said
what any of us said
i'm going through all your cabinets oh
requires key what the hell why am i here
why am i going through all their stuff
why would i do this
how horrible person am i they looked at
me through the upstairs window and they
cowered in fear
oh god no one ever comes here
i'm going through your fridge
no i'm not that's the one thing i'll
respect battery
awesome love that looks like a
suspiciously normal home
with suspiciously normal things in it
that's what they want me to think i know
there's evil in
[Laughter]
hello hi what's up in here you guiding
me no
you lie you lied to me
hello wow that is bright hey
you mind me going through all of your
stuff
oh hey what's up
anybody in here taking a bath are you
think you can just take a bath i'm
reading your notes
okay my name is steve and i'm a writer i
was looking for a quiet place to live
and write so i recently bought this
house
i looked for some information about the
history of the house but the local
authorities said that they don't have
any information about the previous owner
then who did you buy it from where the
hell did you buy it from what do you
mean
what do you mean you don't just get a
house and who writes to themself like
that who's that letter to
this always just ends
why hello something ain't right in here
and i'm gonna stab the first person that
i see in this house
cause something ain't right use oh i'm a
genius
i can't see what i did but i'm a genius
i'm a genius
oh my god oh my oh my
lordy lou i have a fuse i can't see
anything because i don't even have like
a flashlight or something but
god damn
grandma okay all right okay all right
hey who's here
hello big place huh just to write in huh
must be a successful writer huh oh
interesting
oh well that's a little weird hmm it
sure does look like the dude that i
almost hit
good thing someone immortalized that
moment with a painting
a picture picture painting requires
bronze key oh what
what okay
is there like a flashlight that i'm able
to get somewhere
oh oh you you
fine take a fuse okay
i didn't even know that that was
grabbable i have multiple fuses now
but i don't really know why
well i'm coming for you you think
you can run
you will never run i better in here in
the closet
oh that is concerning well that is very
concerning
that's a little concerning is that a
blood stained coat man you got to get
some
you gotta get some uh whatever you used
to get blood out was it baking soda was
it
what do you use i have no idea okay
another fuse i have three fuses now i
don't know if that's important
i'm going through your things still
there's something behind here oh
yes there is okay
i don't know what key it's no longer
possible to live in this house this is
literally
nine days after the last one strange
sounds and shadows are becoming more
common
i talked to one of this area's older
residents and he told me that a doctor
who worked in a small psychiatric
hospital
lived in this house i thought no one
knew the doctor lived a very private
life and was considered strange
i also found out that the locals say you
can get it to a psychiatric hospital
from this house
through some tunnels it doesn't sound
credible but i'll try to explore the
basement better
maybe i'll find something you didn't say
why it was no longer possible to live in
the house though
you made that claim and you did nothing
you said just backed up that claim
i could live in this house sounds dope
sounds awesome
some cool doctor some really cool doctor
all right is that you mr doctor
[Music]
all right that's how it's going to be
he's dork he's dork i can't see his dork
i need a flashlight there's got to be a
flashlight somewhere right
crash bronze key i've been through here
where else is there to go like i have a
key i just don't have
the baron hey
my door is stuck huh
yeah right and for some reason this door
doesn't do anything
so is there something that i missed in
this area
from the get-go yeah
oh i have the key for that interesting
ah very
good fascinating
oh very good oh very good
hello who's there
oh city went off i should check the
panel
maybe it's in the basement yeah maybe
how do i get to the basement
i literally don't know oh yeah now
hey i see someone's leggies oh
no everything's always a demo
god damn it demo version well that was
very good i was enjoying myself
it felt a bit granny-esque but you know
honestly the granny recipe does work i
can't really fault it i was enjoying
myself i really was getting into it i
was starting to have fun with it so
not bad not bad but you know there's
only so much you can do
in a demo
[Music]
so that was three scary games i think we
got all the jump scares out of the way
if there is one more then uh by now
you've seen a lot of scary stuff so it
won't be that scary to you so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i'll see you
in the next video
you